in europa ist krieg
der russische angriff zeichnete sich
über monate ab rückblickend sieht man
putin hat vor einem jahr die
entscheidung getroffen weil man ihm
zuhörte war er ganz klar er hat es auf
die ukraine abgesehen wenn wir also
sagen seid übersehen wird die größte
brocken konzentration auf europäischem
boden seit ende des zweiten weltkriegs
ist dass mindestens im jahr 2020 geplant
reagierten europäische politiker zu spät
haben sie zu lange einem despoten und
seinem regime vertraut geworden eiskalt
belogen der kanzler wurde belogen ich
bei vom russischen außenminister die
gesamte internationale gemeinschaft
waren europäische und deutsche politiker
wirklich machtlos oder fehlte es an
klaren entscheidungen und anmut
achter november 2020 joe biden besiegt
den bisherigen us präsidenten donald
trump beiden amtseinführung im januar
ist eine niederlage für russland
putin hat schnell begriffen dass sich
die dynamik mit beiden amtsantritt
ändern würde beiden setzt sich mehr für
die demokratie in der welt ein putin
muss registriert haben dass es für ihn
ab jetzt schwieriger würde
in einem ersten fernsehinterview findet
beiden klare worte sie kennen wladimir
putin denken sie eher ist ein keller
natürlich
welchem preis muss er bezahlen das
werden sie sehr bald sehen
putin hat schon verstanden dass die
zeiten sich geändert hat man hat einen
usa die wieder präsent ist international
und usa die ihn und seine führung als
ein problem empfindet beiden macht in
seinem ersten telefonat mit putin die
neuen prioritäten klar
der präsident hat putin am nachmittag
angerufen um klarzustellen dass wir im
angesicht der anhaltenden russischen
aggression die souveränität der ukraine
voll unterstützen
seit russland die krim 2014 annektiert
hat ist auch die ost ukraine die
stabilisiert aus ukrainischer
perspektive wurde ein krieg gegen die
ukraine geführt seit 2014 das war ein
ewiger kriegszustand
schon im januar 2021 bittet der
ukrainische präsident sie lenski den
neuen us präsidenten um waffen der
stimmt zu als beiden ins amt kam war der
boden für eine viel intensivere
verteidigungs kooperation zwischen den
usa und der ukraine bereitet und putin
war das klar der
achtzehnter märz 2021 putin feiert die
annexion der ukrainischen halbinsel krim
sieben jahre zuvor in einem
ausverkauften fußballstadion in moskau
putin selbst heizt die menge an bitte
wenige tage später zirkulieren
handyvideos sie zeigen russische panzer
unterwegs an die ukrainische grenze
anfang april veröffentlicht die
russische regierung propaganda aufnahmen
angeblich zeigen sie eine übung man
reagiere auf ein nato manöver
der unterschied ist die nato macht etwa
übungen so mit 10 12 tausend soldaten
und russland bindet 60 bis 90.000
soldaten zusammen wenn wir das verlegen
wollten hätten wir in deutschland gar
nicht die transportkapazität
also wenn solche übungen gemacht werden
ist das in der regel ein jahr vorher
geplant
und dann kam diese gruppe konzentration
mit der konkrete aggressive sachen geübt
wurden also angriffe gegen die süd
ukraine küste
[Musik]
während die übung läuft bestreitet
russland einen angriff vorzubereiten
[Musik]
wie und wohin wir truppen auf unserem
territorium verlegen ist unsere eigene
angelegenheit das sollte niemanden
beunruhigen russland hat noch nie
jemanden bedroht
der ukrainische präsident see lenski
besucht anfang april die front in der
ost ukraine
denn die russischen truppen tauchen
inzwischen nicht mehr nur in der nähe
der krim auf sondern auch weiter
nördlich an der ostgrenze
zielinski appelliert daher an die nato
er brauche schutz
forderte angesichts der wachsenden
spannungen mit russland den
nato-beitritt der ukraine voranzutreiben
er sehe darin den einzigen weg zum
frieden ein nato-beitritt der ukraine
ist seit 2008 ein thema aber eine
entscheidung steht aus und in berlin hat
man im frühjahr 2021 andere sorgen er
muss damals auch intensiv briefen lassen
im auswärtigen ausschuss und in anderen
gremien aber da ging es eher um
afghanistan und überhaupt nicht
außerdem tobt der wahlkampf
unsere aufmerksamkeit war durch den
bundestagswahlkampf abgelenkt im april
noch durch die kanzlerkandidatur in der
union zweitens die panini und aber kein
blick in richtung russland das muss man
auch ganz offen sagen wochen lang
trainieren russische truppen an der
grenze zur ukraine russische diplomaten
versuchen derweil einen keil zwischen
den westen und die ukraine zu treiben
unsere kollegen im westen glauben immer
noch dass es notwendig ist die
ukrainische führung jederzeit zu
unterstützen muss inklusive ihrer
absolut inakzeptablen handlungen und
aussagen
die eu-außenminister schalten sie schon
im april ein hören den ukrainischen
außenminister an der ernst der lage ist
klar
so viele truppen hat die russische armee
an der grenze zur ukraine noch nie zuvor
zusammen gezogen
natürlich besorgt uns dass
spätestens da hätte man im frühjahr 21
aufwachen sollen dass russland nicht
einfach irgendeine übung macht sondern
konkret übt einen anderen staat
anzugreifen da hätte man schon früher
noch reagieren müssen doch dann scheint
der spuk vorbei die russische
militärführung behauptet dass alle
truppen wieder abgezogen würden
wir haben mitbekommen dass russland
einige truppen von der grenze abgezogen
aber ein bedeutender teil der truppen
die ausrüstung ist da geblieben daher
behalten wir die situation weiter sehr
genau im auge
als reaktion schicken die amerikaner
mehr waffen in die ukraine und
verstärken die ausbildung
das war ein wettrennen russland musste
sich schneller auf diese invasion
vorbereiten als wir den ukrainern dabei
helfen könnten ihren widerstand zu
organisieren
putin feiert derweil am 9 mai dem
jahrestag des sieges im zweiten
weltkrieg
er will nicht
wieder herstellen er will das russische
imperium wiederherstellen und russland
ist eine koloniale macht eine kolonie
das ist die ukraine in putins augen
deren präsident akzeptiert das nicht und
entwirft eine gegen erzählung die
pressekonferenz in dem flugzeug hangars
sollte aufmerksamkeit erregen es sollte
auch eine gewisse beziehung zu diesem
kriegszustand in dem sich die ukraine
damals befand herstellen wir sehen ja
wie geschickt er die vermeintliche
medienmacht oder gar übermacht durch die
russische propaganda durchkreuzt im
frühjahr 2021 weiten von russland
unterstützte separatisten die kämpfe in
der ost ukraine aus beschießen auch
schulen die ukraine lädt deutsche
politiker ein sie sollen den krieg mit
eigenen augen sehen robert habeck hat
damals in seiner partei so einen kleinen
schock versetzt indem er in diese region
gefahren ist und dann sich von dort
meldete mit der forderung man solle doch
die ukraine mit waffen unterstützen mit
waffenlieferungen
in die ukraine
sicherheitspolitisch allein gelassen und
sie es allein gelassen die gruppen auch
manchem osten und deutschland liefert
nachtsichtgeräte keine
kampfmittelbeseitigung und doch habe ich
mal klar durch geld irgendwas muss man
halt tun schon damals im mai 2021 hatte
robert habeck heute regierungsmitglied
die lage richtig analysiert die ukraine
brauche hilfe und waffen doch der
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen pasta rapex
forderung nicht also wenn man annalena
baerbock verhalten von damals ansieht
dann war ihre linie sehr klar im ganz
klassisch grün und friedensbewegte keine
waffen an die ukraine liefern robert
habeck wurde de facto zurückgepfiffen
von ihr zu der zeit begann die heiße
phase des wahlkampfs und die grünen
wollten sich nicht als die partei
aufstellen die plötzlich eine
militärische unterstützung der ukraine
fordert präsident seelands gekämpft in
dem frühjahr genau um diese
unterstützung des westens er registriert
der westen ist sich nicht einig wie er
mit putin umgehen soll
ich glaube in dieser hinsicht viel dem
westen eine klare haltung gegenüber
russland
das müssen wir ganz klar sehen dass es
da auch ein vertrauensverlust gibt auf
seiten der ukraine
dass man dass man einfach nicht gehört
wird und dass das das da zu wenig
unterstützung kommt wo man immer wieder
gesehen hat dass russland sich nicht an
regeln hält also regeln werden permanent
gebrochen aber es passiert halt nix
auf dem ersten gipfel zwischen
us-präsident beiden und wladimir putin
im juni 2021 wird auch das problem der
russischen truppen an der grenze zur
ukraine diskutiert
putin gibt sich diplomatisch und
beiden beruhigt anschließend die
öffentlichkeit
ich habe ihm gesagt das ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt einen kumbaya moment haben wir
das früher genannt haben alle umarmen
sich und haben sich aber es ist weder im
interesse ihres landes noch in unserem
dass wir wieder in einen kalten krieg
abgleichen
putin gibt sich versöhnlich alles taktik
sagen menschen die ihn lange kennen
ich habe zwölf jahre damit verbracht
wladimir putin zu bekämpfen und immer
hat er gelogen immer
vereinbarungen sind sinnlos er ist dann
pathologischer lügner und hat jedes
staatsoberhaupt vor der invasion
angehört
auch die us-regierung unter beiden traut
putin nicht und liefert der ukraine mehr
waffen im sommer 2021 besucht wolodimir
selensky deutschland das weiter mit sich
selbst zu tun hat er wirbt um hilfe das
leid der ukraine erkennt die kanzlerin
an doch konkrete maßnahmen fehlanzeige
deutschland das darf ich für mich sagen
wird sich einsetzen weiter dass wir
fortschritte erreichen aber wir müssen
eben auch gerade in den letzten tagen
wieder feststellen dass ukrainische
soldaten ums leben gekommen sind und das
ist sehr schwierig
genau am tag von selen sqeez besuch in
berlin erscheint ein artikel von putin
über die einheit der russen und ukrainer
der artikel war im grunde genommen eine
geschichtspolitische kriegserklärung
eine geschichtspolitische
kriegserklärung also ukrainer und russen
sind ein volk die ukraine sind
eigentlich keine nation der staat ist
eigentlich auch kein richtiger staat
wenn ein präsident unter seinem namen
artikel veröffentlich wohl sagt die
nachbarstaaten sozusagen haben kein
anrecht darauf start zu sein das wäre
einfach an die ankündigung eines
überfalls im grunde demokratien haben
die tendenz solche hässlichen wahrheiten
solche bedrohlichen wahrheiten lieber
fern zu halten
seit seinem amtsantritt im jahr 2000 für
putin kriege in georgien tschetschenien
syrien brutal blutig das hatte für ihn
jedoch nie konsequenzen er kommt durch
mit seinem militärischen abenteurertum
ist zahlt sich für ihn aus und der welt
ist das egal niemand sie den wirklich
zur rechenschaft wenn man begreift wie
das auf putin wirkt ist völlig klar dass
er einfach immer weitermacht
fünfzehnter august 2021 der westen
erlebt in kabul ein desaster
putin nimmt diese schwäche und
zerrissenheit der westlichen
bündnispartner genau war die art und
weise wie dann der abzug und dieses
desaster des abzugs erfolgt ist also
völlige europäische handlungsunfähigkeit
hat putin vor augen geführt die schwäche
der europäischen staaten die mangelnde
geschlossenheit und letztlich auch die
militärische schwäche das zweite das er
gesehen hat dass die westlichen staaten
nicht koordiniert vorgehen planlos
vorgehen das amerikanische mit
herausgezogen wird bevor die anderen
staaten irgendwie informiert sind und
daraus den schluss zu ziehen
wesentlichen anlage auf eine
militärische krise geschlossen zu
reagieren lag eigentlich nach mainz hat
putin es schon gerochen dieser westen
ist komplett verunsichert fünf tage nach
dem fall kabuls merkel besucht putin in
moskau um die lage in der ukraine zu
entschärfen
der russische präsident hatte in den
monaten zuvor in der frage nicht einen
zentimeter preisgegeben wir hatten eben
meines erachtens auch das problem in
deutschland dass die kanzlerin schon von
ihrer natur her nicht der mensch ist der
strategisch wirklichen kurswechsel
vornehmen so ich glaube das hätte es
aber gebraucht im verhältnis zu russland
doch einen neuen kurs leitet merkel bei
ihrem letzten besuch in moskau nicht
mehr ein
[Musik]
doch worte hatten putin auch zuvor nie
gestoppt berger den gesprächen sehr oft
den kopf zurecht gerückt aber sie hat
glaube ich keine möglichkeit gesehen ihn
mit gewalt zu begegnen
man hatte keine keine strategie man
hatte eben wie gesagt auch kein hebel
neben den dialog gehört eine politik der
stärke ja sogar der abschreckung das ist
das problem von
deutschland das ist das problem von der
europäischen union das ist auch das
problem von der nato
die friedensdividende die hoffnung dass
es keine notwendigkeit mehr gebe
weiter zu rüsten und es ist zu lange
ausgeblendet worden wie entschlossen und
wie kalt putin seine schritte setzt kühl
kalkulierend hat putin seine gegner über
die jahre auch ein russisches gas
gewöhnt nicht zuletzt die deutschen die
sitzen nun in der falle ende august 2021
ist angela merkel in kiew schärfe und
klarheit sind gefragt aber die zeigt nur
see lenski er zeigt auf was die deutsche
abhängigkeit von russischem gas für sein
land bedeutet
man kann doch nicht ignorieren dass
diese situation nicht nur für die
ukraine sondern auch für europa
gefährlich ist man kann doch nicht
leugnen dass gas eine waffe ist man
sieht auch wenn die preise in europa
kontrolliert und in die höhe treibt
[Musik]
putin hält uns im westen für schwach und
zerstritten und so hat er auch gas als
waffe vor der invasion eingesetzt hat
den preis in die höhe getrieben obwohl
die inflation sowieso schon außer
kontrolle gerät
er glaubt dass er so fixiert auf die
wirtschaft sind dass wir nicht den mut
haben werden uns mit ihm anzuhören
man darf sich energiepolitisch oder in
anderen entscheidenden fragen nicht
abhängig machen von einem partner der
eben nicht damit die wirtschaftliche
verflechtung verfolgt sondern völlig
andere ziele dann kann eigentlich so
eine partnerschaft nicht funktionieren
aber angela merkel ändert erst im sommer
2021 in kiew ihre meinung zum russischen
gas erkennt jetzt plötzlich die gefahr
dass umdenken von angela merkel war zwar
richtig kam aber viel zu spät und im
nachhinein muss man sagen dass sie die
lage falsch eingeschätzt hat die dienste
haben zwar immer ordentlich berichtet
aber es ist eben die politische
bewertung gefragt gewesen und ich denke
dass sie ihre politische bewertung heute
revidieren würde das heißt der
bundesnachrichtendienst hat die
kanzlerin gewarnt dass das problem ernst
ist mein eindruck ist dass der
bundesnachrichtendienst sehr gut
informiert war zwei tage nach merkels
besuch der ukrainische nationalfeiertag
vielleicht der letzte deutschland kann
sich trotz einer information über die
russische gefahren nicht dazu
durchringen der ukraine mit waffen zu
helfen andere staaten schon wir haben
hier in den letzten jahren gesehen dass
nato staaten die ukraine erheblich
unterstützt haben sie haben erhebliche
finanzielle hilfe erhalten man hat
waffen schon seit jahren geliefert und
dazu gehören auch drohnen also
kampfdrohnen die insbesondere
insbesondere die türkei geliefert hat
also die aussage die ukraine wäre allein
gestanden stimmt nicht selen ski hatte
schon monate zuvor gewarnt dass es nicht
nur um die ukraine gehen werde verbote
ja ich bin der meinung dass dies der
dritte weltkrieg werden
und europa die länder der europäischen
union
sie alle würden darunter leiden
oktober 2021
die eu hält sogar einen
solidaritätsgefühl in kiew ab es scheint
als hätte die eu den ernst der lage
verstanden
die eu ist in russland immer geschlossen
aufgetreten hat vor konsequenzen gewarnt
aber im nachhinein waren es
lippenbekenntnisse und die europäische
union hat ihre starken papiere nie durch
handlungen unterfüttert putin wusste das
sind einfach bekenntnisse die werden
sowieso nicht umgesetzt ende oktober
2021 diskutiert die nato wie effizient
ihre atomare abschreckung kapazität ist
so ernst ist die lage
wir werden russlands die
stabilisierendes verhalten nicht auf die
gleiche weise beantworten wir haben auch
nicht vor neue landgestützten raketen in
europa zu stationieren wir setzen
vielmehr auf ein ausgewogenes
politisches und militärisches paket und
wir werden maßnahmen ergreifen damit
unsere nukleare abschreckung
funktioniert und bereit ist
putin antwortete am gleichen tag auf die
botschaft der nato er sei doch derjenige
der bedroht werde von der ukraine
sie haben völlig recht zu einer formalen
mitgliedschaft mag es nie kommen aber
das territorium wird militärisch
aufgerüstet
und das stellt eine bedrohung für die
russische föderation
das ist sozusagen das kuba syndrom das
ist nicht nur flug in das ist also die
sicherheitspolitische elite in russland
die so denkt dass sie angst haben dass
wir in eine situation kommen könnten in
der die usa 1962 waren als die
sowjetunion raketen auf kuba stationiert
hat putins angst die usa könnten die
ukraine als raketenbasis benutzen so wie
es einst die sowjetunion mit kuba vor
hatte die logik des kalten kriegs man
muss natürlich dazu sagen die raketen
von denen er gesprochen hat gibt es ja
noch nicht putin reagiert ende oktober
trotzdem so als sei die ukraine bereits
das neue kuba
satellitenbilder tauchen in der
us-presse auf sie zeigen neue russische
truppen an der grenze zur ukraine
das ist falsch nur eine neue fake news
kampagne der us medien
doch immer neue aufnahmen von satelliten
zeigen etwas anderes als unsere
westlichen partner haben uns
informationen zur verfügung gestellt die
belegen dass viele russische truppen an
den grenzen der ukraine auf maschine
ich hoffe die welt sieht nun wer
wirklich frieden will und wer fast
100.000 soldaten an unseren grenzen
zusammenziehen
parallel spitzt sich die lage im
nachbarland der ukraine zu
weißrussland der wichtigste partner für
putins angriffspläne schleust
flüchtlinge an die polnische grenze um
druck aufzubauen
die ukrainische regierung durchschaut
das und warnt die nato
russlands militär manöver die
energiekrise in europa der dramatische
ansatz von flüchtlingen als waffe an den
grenzen polens und litauens mit
weißrussland dazu die
desinformationskampagne all das gehört
zusammen
es sind elemente eines hybrid krieges
den russland gehen die europäische und
transatlantische gesellschaft für
die russischen truppen umzingeln die
ukraine diesmal veröffentlicht die
regierung russlands keiner pr-bilder
wenn wir also sagen seit oktober sehen
wir die größte truppen konzentration auf
europäischem boden seit ende des zweiten
weltkriegs ist das sicherlich mindestens
im jahr
2020 geplant worden
dann eher begrenzte interventionen aber
an einen intensiven totalen krieg
glaubten wir nicht selbst als die
amerikaner sagten dass er unmittelbar
bevorsteht es fiel uns sehr schwer daran
zu glauben
nato-treffen in riga ende november
2021 viele mitglieder sind sehr
beunruhigt die nerven liegen blank bei
einer frage nach der russischen
einflusssphäre in europa explodiert der
generalsekretär
wir sollten uns alle klar sein dass die
frage eine behauptung widerspiegelt die
inakzeptabel ist nämlich dass es eine
russische einflusssphäre gibt russland
hat kein veto nicht das letzte wort und
kein recht auf eine einflusssphäre um am
ende seinen direkt nachbarn zu
kontrollieren
joe biden sucht den richtigen kurs und
warnt immer eindringlicher vor einem
russischen überfall am siebten dezember
2021 ein letzter folgenloser virtueller
gipfel mit putin ich hatte nie den
eindruck das atelier eskalieren will er
will vor den usa auf augenhöhe als
großmacht anerkannt werden und er will
die kontrolle über das was er für seine
interessensphäre hält und das schließt
die ukraine mit 1
seelands gesucht im dezember wieder die
hilfe der eu bittet um härtere
sanktionen gegen russland bevor es zu
spät ist
seit acht jahren haben wir krieg in
unserem land
wir verstehen daher am besten dass
sanktionen nur etwas bringen wenn man
sie einsetzt bevor die situation
eskaliert
danach ist es zu spät
doch neue sanktionen kommen nicht putin
verfolgt seine pläne weiter er greift
nun auch die nato auf einer
pressekonferenz direkt an
ihr wollt von mir garantien dabei seid
ihr es die uns garantien geben müssen
jetzt sofort ein staat jahrzehntelang
nur zu quatschen
putin und seine militärs hatten der nato
kurz zuvor geschrieben was sie wirklich
wollen die usa müssten sich aus europa
zurückziehen die nato aus der
erweiterung rückgängig gemacht werden
ein ultimatum kein verhandlungsangebot
das gehört zu ihrem 3 eine liste mit
unerfüllbaren forderungen aufstellen
damit die andere seite gar nicht darauf
eingehen kann und dann diese weigerung
zu nutzen um loszuschlagen
putin will eine rückkehr zum kalten
krieg er will einen ausschluss der
bisherigen warschauer pakt staaten aus
der nato alles was die bevölkerung
mittel und osteuropas erreicht haben
ende der 80er jahre will er über den
haufen werfen durch militärischen druck
das ist auch ein blick in die zukunft
eine akute bedrohung für osteuropäische
nato-staaten weil russland deren gebiete
beansprucht in der strategische fragen
kann man reden muss man reden aber über
imperiale arten die zurückweisen in
vergangene jahrhunderte kann man nicht
reden da kam dagegen kann man sich eben
nur verteidigen die ukraine beobachtet
anfang 2022 dass russland auch angriffs
truppen in weißrussland stationiert
nördlich von kiew die schlinge zieht
sich zu im januar wurden auch mal
100.000 blutkonserven an die russischen
streitkräfte ausgegeben er war
vollkommen klar dass es zum krieg kommen
allerdings ist es auch gebot des westens
bis zum letzten tag zu verhandeln wir
haben ja bis zum letzten tag telefonate
gespräche treffen gehabt
und die neue bundesregierung plötzlich
mittendrin
erkenntnis durchsetze das könnte jetzt
doch wirklich etwas ernstes sein was
machen eigentlich dieser ganzen panzer
dar dann kam ja die phase jeder reist
überall hin jeder reist in die ukraine
auch der neue kanzler schaltet sich nun
ein besucht kiew dann moskau da merkte
man dann auf dem rückflug diese
anspannung die abgefallen ist also er
war schon enorm erleichtert dass diese
reise unfallfrei abgegangen ist und mein
eindruck war dass scholz gedacht hat das
ist jetzt jedenfalls unwahrscheinlicher
geworden dass putin angreift neunzehnter
februar am rande der
sicherheitskonferenz lassen
us-geheimdienste durchsickern putin hat
den befehl für einen angriff auf die
ukraine gegeben
zielinski wird beklatscht aber es kommt
nicht zu konkreten maßnahmen auch nicht
gegenüber russland am selben tag schickt
putin eine weitere botschaft an die welt
er testet neue atomwaffenfähige raketen
das war eindeutig ein politisches signal
an den westen wir werden in die ukraine
einfahren und wir verfügen über
nuklearer fähigkeiten also müsst euch
nicht ein
dann setzten russische truppen putins
plan um angriff auf die ukraine
hätten wir russland aufhalten können auf
jeden fall haben wir nicht alles getan
was nötig war um es zu versuchen das ist
sicher wir waren nicht hart genug wir
waren zu selbstgefällig wir haben uns zu
sehr in unserer bequemlichkeit
eingerichtet es sind unsere führer die
versagt haben und viel zu selbstgefällig
waren
man hätte ja putin nichts bieten können
das ihnen zufrieden stellt aus meiner
sicht bei der krieg nicht vermeiden er
wäre nur dann vermeidbar gewesen wenn
wir die ukraine geopfert hätten wenn die
ukraine von uns aufgefordert wäre seine
souveränität aufzugeben
wenn putin siegen sollte dann würde das
russische militär an der grenze der eu
stehen da fehlt der blick auf uns selber
nämlich das keineswegs ausgemacht ist ob
nicht auch wir in gefahr geraten
es wird jetzt sehr ungemütlich für
europäische länder die direkt an die
ukraine grenzen aber eigentlich stehen
wir alle an dieser front wir müssen
begreifen dass wir alle nationalen macht
instrumente die wir haben in nächster
zukunft einsetzen müssen um akteure wie
putins russland zu isolieren und um
ihren einfluss zurückzudrängen
[Musik]